in our series on the new normal we look
at how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives and those
changes affect the way we work the way
we learn socialize and also travel now
many of us have been under stay at home
orders for around two months now and so
we're looking at new and safe ways to
even though we're staying at home still
see friends and family and we're joined
in this effort by a senior managing
editor at C net Dan Ackerman he's from
our partners there over at C net and
he's joining us from his home in Vermont
dan good morning
video games come to mind as one option
beyond the facetiming and the zooming
that people are doing but walk me
through how video games can be a social
activity sure we've all played online
games before that was popular even
before this but what I'm finding now
especially for kids is that video games
have become what we call the new play
date it's how they get together with
their friends my third grader goes
online and he plays roblox and it plays
minecraft and either E chats in the app
with his friends or frankly he just has
an iPad behind him and turns on FaceTime
and he's talking to his buddy who's
playing the game at the same time as him
and that's the the closest they can get
right now to getting together in person
and every parent I talked to it's some
version of this whether it's fortnight
or minecraft or roblox or anything else
yeah I've been using brawl stars I think
it's called with my older son in Israel
there's a time change difference but we
can both get on at the same time be in
the same game it's a wonderful way to
socialize for people who aren't into
video games what other activities are
there beyond FaceTime sure I'm doing a
lot more zoom happy hours I think
everyone else is also it was kind of a
in edge case before you go who would do
that that that sounds crazy but now
since it's what we can do it's what
everyone is doing I've gotten together
with people I've worked with you know 15
20 years ago and we all get on the
little nine person Brady Bunch screen
and zoom where you can see everyone at
the same time and it's not as good as
being there in person but for people who
are spread out around the country it's
actually something you wouldn't normally
do so I think that's super interesting
and of course people have turned it into
a trivia game
into into baking with other people my
mother is going to do her normal
quilting and crocheting get together but
they're going to do it over zoom instead
of going to a bed-and-breakfast and
everyone sitting together so anything
you could do in real life they're
finding ways to recreate through these
video sharing apps yeah it's really cool
and it's it's surprising how quickly you
forget that you're on a digital device
and you just go into happy hour as it
would normally feel and I've also done
the cooking as well the one thing I
can't really imagine recreating
digitally is the kind of group fitness
class that kind of activity where
there's energy in the room because
they're all together is that possible to
recreate in any way and the energy you
kind of have to bring that yourself but
I've seen two big versions of this one
is a lot of the big companies like
peloton they've shifted to a remote
model where you know it's you can use
the bike or you can use your own
equipment and they really want you to
use their streaming app which has become
very popular just by itself and that
every small independent health and
fitness person I know who maybe does
classes or yoga or tower readings or
anything like that they've shifted to
doing a streaming model where they'll
have a live event once or twice a week
or even daily and they're their members
can come in and share that or they'll
post you know a bunch of new videos
every week and maybe do a live one as a
kickoff so even for small business
people it's become a really big deal to
shift that business model and no it's
not the same as going to the room
together with everybody else but I'm
surprised pleasantly I think at how
quickly people have taken to this all
right I may give it a shot although as
you say the energy you have to bring
that yourself
I can try Dan Ackerman thank you very
much I appreciate it